l'attaque terroriste du Hamas contre
Israël est-elle en train de faire voler
la gauche française en éclat depuis
samedi dernier la France insoumise et
ses alliés de l'anupe se déchirent au
sujet de la position à adopter face à
l'assaut brutal du Hamas contre l'État
hébreu tout commence le 7 octobre à la
vue de l'horreur subie par les civiles
israéliens les froid s'empare
instantanément de la classe politique
française qui a apporté d'une même voix
son soutien à Israël d'emblé la France
insoumise fait tâche l'offensive armée
des forces palestiniennes mené par le
Hamas intervient dans un contexte
d'intensification de la politique
d'occupation israélienne à gaz en
sjordanie et à Jérusalem Est refusant
par principe de prendre le parti
d'Israël Jean-Luc Mélenchon renvoie dos
à dos les deux belligérants toute
violence déchaîné contre Israël et à
Gaza ne prouve qu'une chose la violence
produit et ne reproduit qu'elle-même
d'autres encore comme le député éfi
Louis Boyard pointe du doigt la
colonisation et les exactions dont
l'État hébreu est responsable ces
dernières années en Palestine dès lors
la discorde est semée dans les rangs
socialistes toujours considérer les
juifs comme responsables de ce qui leur
arrive c'est une constante du discours
antisémite lance la sénatrice PS le
Laurence Rossignol le député socialiste
Jérôme Gedge a quant à lui exprimé son
dégoût face à des idiots utiles du Hamas
mardi dernier la discore vir au scandale
lorsqu'un imbroulio sémantique s'invite
dans la polémique lors d'une conférence
de presse à l'Assemblée nationale la
présidente du groupe fill Mathilde pano
refuse de qualifier le Hamas
d'organisation terroriste lui préférant
une autre définition c'est une la
branche armée qui aujourd'hui est
responsable de crime de guerre voilà et
dont et c'est largement documenté vous
pourrez a répondu sur terroriste en fait
une vague d'indignation gagne aussitôt
la coalition de gauche dont l'unité
semble aujourd'hui durablement mise à
mal parfois l'Union est un combat
parfois effectivement il faut faire
respecter une parole et moi ce que je
veux faire aujourd'hui ça n'est pas
m'aligner sur une position qui ne serait
pas la mienne le terrorisme n'est à
aucun moment acceptable la S semble même
avoir gagné les insoumis dont l'un des
ténors François Ruffin a pris ses
distances avec la rhétorique
mélanchoniste en condamnant sans réserve
une organisation fanatique terroriste
qui a toujours été l'adversaire des
progressistes au Proche Orient la nup
va-t-elle survivre à ses divisions
internes rien n'est moins sûr Mélenchon
il a réussi le tour de force de tordre
le bras aux trois autres parties de la
gauche de gouvernement et qu'aujourd'hui
ils se sont en effet soumis à la France
insoumise et c'est un petit peu une
sorte de perfusion dont ils savent que
s'ils se l'arrach leurs chances de de
vie ou de survie sont quasi Nules et Gan
luuc Mélenchon il a conscience de ça et
c'est pour ça aussi qu'il voyez que
toute la gauche s'est élevée contre lui
il n'a pas bougé d'une virgule dans sa
position sur le
sujet